hey there before we get into the
comparison i want to leave you the
wonderful viewer with a few disclaimers
all of these games were running off
their internal ssds
the timer starts right when we hit play
on both consoles and the clock doesn't
stop until we've loaded into the game
this means that there may be a very
small margin of error as we fiddle with
menus to load into a save
it's also worth noting that some of
destiny and monster hunter world's load
times are somewhat dependent on their
respective servers
we tested both versions in similar
network environments but your results
may vary
finally for games with optimizations
like 15 and monster hunter we set them
to prioritize frame rate for these tests
also keep in mind these games are
running off their most up-to-date
versions and have not received next gen
updates at the time of this recording
as of now destiny 2 is the only game in
this list scheduled to get a next gen
update
things could change in the coming months
weeks or years
anyway let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign